el oído externo incluye el pabellón
auricular que recolecta las ondas
sonoras y el canal auditivo que
transporta las ondas sonoras al tímpano
una capa muy delgada de tejido que
separa el oído externo del oído medio
las ondas sonoras hacen que el tímpano
vibre lo que a su vez hace vibrar tres
huesos muy pequeños del oído medio
llamados martillo
yunque
y estribo
qué pasa en Las vibraciones del sonido
hacia el oído interno
[Música]
el oído interno traduce las vibraciones
en señales eléctricas que son recogidas
por el nervio auditivo
enviadas al cerebro e interpretadas como
sonido este proceso complejo ocurre
instantáneamente y nos permite escuchar
los sonidos que se producen alrededor
nuestro